Speaker 1: So the big news, the big news cycle
over the last 16, 18 hours or so is that it is
here it is here. Omicron has been confirmed
in the United States now. Is this meaningful?
We don't know. Is it newsworthy in the sense
of is it surprising? It's probably already been
here for some weeks. And number three, does
this finding make us question the presidency
of the travel bans that have been put in place?
We're going to talk about all of these different
questions, but the big news and we're kind of
in the omni Akron now, I'm saying it the way
now I'm saying it the way, Biden said the other
day. Omicron, which Joe Biden referred to as the
omni Akron Omicron, is here in the United States,
and now we're in the Omicron found in this state.
And sooner Macron found in that state phase of
the story without yet knowing what that actually
means. So CNBC reporting yesterday CDC confirms
first case of Omicron COVID variant in California.
The CDC said Wednesday it confirmed the first
U.S. case of the new heavily mutated coronavirus
variant called Omicron, detected in Northern
California. White House Chief Medical Adviser
Anthony Fauci said the patient, who was fully
vaccinated, had just returned to the San Francisco
area November 22nd after traveling in South
Africa tested positive Nov. 29. The again the
timing given that they got back at this point.
What is that eight 10 days ago suggests? It's
probably been here for some time. The individual
is self-quarantining and all close contacts have
been contacted and thus far have tested negative.
We feel good that this patient not only had mild
symptoms, but actually had the symptoms
appear to be improving. That is good news.
The article, because it is CNBC, mentions
that there was a big swing in the stock
market yesterday after this case was confirmed.
And this is one of those things where it's sort
of like really guys like the idea is that
at any time the stock market reflects all
known information about the state of the economy
or companies that are at least measured by the
stock stock market. Is it really news that there
was one case found in the United States? I mean,
when almost a week ago or even longer, about a
week ago, we said it's probably already here.
A 500 plus point swing because of the announcement
seems to me like not a particularly efficient
market, given that any reasonable person would
have inferred there is going to be cases here and
we still don't yet know how serious they are now.
That's the next thing that I want to talk about.
We are starting to anecdotally get information
about the believed severity of all micron
cases and whether this means we're headed in some
kind of terrible direction, or whether this might
actually be a milder variant. There are more and
more, even from this morning, anecdotal claims
that those who are vaccinated don't really have
to worry more about Omicron. Whatever level you
were worried before is the level. You should be
worried now, but that if you're unvaccinated,
you should worry. We're starting to see more and
more. That story is being told more and more,
although it is not yet a story that we
can definitively confirm. For example,
South Africa expert previous infection
doesn't protect against Omicron, but shots do.
People infected with earlier variants of COVID
do not appear to be protected against Omicron.
But vaccination will prevent serious illness.
A top South African scientist says We believe
that previous infection does not provide
protection from Omicron, says Anne van Got Bourg,
expert at the National Institute for Communicable
Diseases in South Africa, outlining early research
into into the newly emerged variant. She says
doctors are seeing an increase for Omicron
reinfections. We believe the number of cases will
increase exponentially in all provinces of the
country that South Africa with a low vaccination
level. We believe that vaccines will still,
however, protect against severe disease. That's
really the whole story at this point in time.
So now let's kind of summarize, Omicron has
been here for weeks. This is an individual
who came back from South Africa November 22nd. If
we believe that they brought it from South Africa
rather than we don't know what their connection
was, maybe they got it from someone else
in a whole bunch of countries and it already was
on November 22nd. It's likely been here for weeks.
Number two, the question as to whether it
is milder or not remains an open question
because with every claim right now there is a
counterclaim. Most of the cases in South Africa
are mild well, but most of the cases in South
Africa are in young people so far that we know of,
and you need 10 14 days to see what the disease
progression is. Well, a lot of the cases in South
Africa are in the unvaccinated. Well, that's
because a lot of the young are unvaccinated in
South Africa. Is is one the cause or is one the
effect? We just don't know at this point in time.
Is it not more deadly on an infection fatality
rate basis, but by being more transmissible,
more people will die because more people will get
it right? We don't know the answer to that at this
point in time. Do vaccines protect at all against
serious disease? Well, what about the third dose?
If you have the third dose, are you more protected
against Omicron? It seems so from early data,
but we still don't know. And then the third piece
of this is what does this mean about travel bans?
Because there is at this point, a situation where
South Africa did the right thing by saying, Hey,
we sequenced this, we found this. This is a new
variant and oh, well, it came from South Africa.
It's now not even totally clear it might have come
from European countries, and it might have been
brought to sell because South Africa was the first
to say it. South Africa and southern Africa are
being punished in terms of travel bans when it's
everywhere anyway, right? The travel bans seem to
happen at a time when it's already spread.
They are of unclear efficacy at actually
doing the thing they're supposed to do, and
by the time we have this much information,
it seems to already be too late. So there's a
real question as to the wisdom of these kind
of targeted travel bans. Everything remains
preliminary, and the people who haven't been
paying attention or modifying their behavior
or getting vaccinated all along are generally
speaking, not going to do anything differently.
I do believe that. Even the hyperbolic claims,
which are not yet backed by evidence about Omicron
will get some people who are unvaccinated to go
and get vaccinated, but not a whole bunch of
them curious to hear from you if you agree